money cargo is a member of The Sovereign
Council head of the Sudan's people
Liberation movements the North and a
mediator who met both General abuhan and
ahmedi yesterday joining us now on the
phone thank you very much indeed for
being with us what is your reaction to
what is happening in Sudan now given the
fact that you had that meeting just a
few hours ago
thank you for having me uh
there is a fighting around me here and
then you can hear the morals and the
facilities but anyway it is a disturbing
and worrying separation whoever wins is
a loser and we we ought to do something
about it we try to do that and I mean
three days ago myself Gabriela and uh
and and many we try to talk to both
generals the SRH and the Sudan armed
forces and we actually reach some sort
of understanding that they freeze the
situation uh till we know we're supposed
actually to meet this morning at 10
which is his most of them and then they
both meet
with us so that we Defuse The Situation
our preference was that we needed
immediate solution of the immediate
problem that we need to freeze the
situation and then disengage the forces
and because both both sides are in
battle formations uh positions and that
one was the recipe War which have
actually happened uh now it is
unfortunate that it happened we are
still exerting many other efforts trying
to talk to boss journalists and trying
to uh
appeal to them so that if they could
make immediate ceasefire and again
freeze the situation until we find a
solution uh Wars end on tables and we
would want this one to chase immediately
so that we ended on the table they have
tried it and it is a very devastating
and it's going to continue if it
continues it's going to be departed
devastating and the losses are going to
be very very high I'm not talking about
the the final solution the final
solution is the second priority now the
first priority is to make a ceasefire
media ceasefire and freeze the situation
what looks like a military jet flying
over the city at the moment during the
mediation efforts that you had over the
last few weeks and the meetings that you
had with the generals on both sides did
you have any indication at all that
there was a chance that this situation
could arise
well actually it is up surprise because
both sides assured us within all these
meetings that we had that they are not
going to move they are going to freeze
the situation uh if they were to be
believed then we were saying that
situation could not have escalated as
such as it is now we thought it's not
going to sculpt and actually I was on my
way uh to them so that we we talked them
out of a sudden we uh things took a Toca
dive immediately it was a surprise to us
who were very closely following the
situation of course when you put forces
in a in a battle formation and in a very
close way you expect something to happen
but if you have a strong commanders they
will also control not to happen but
since when they went ahead anyway we
don't know who's started this and it is
unfortunate whoever started it and it is
also unfortunate whoever tried to wins
it is also losing much
so that is music in terms of what
happens next with regard to mediation
given the situation that we're seeing
now in Sudan should those mediation
efforts come from inside the country or
do you think it is going to take some
external pressure to bring both sides
together and result in at least some
sort of temporary ceasefire
uh I mean if if there is an an outside
mediation that I've been going to be
listened to that of course would be
welcomed by by us Sudanese and welcome
by everybody and should be welcomed by
by the journalists but up to now the
solution is still within the bounds of
the two generous the priority is that
Sudan is bleeding we need to stop that
then after we can look at the final
related Solutions
the head of the rsf has said that uh the
rsf has no intention of harming any
civilians but what are your concerns
about the civilian population in Sudan
well it doesn't select I know the war
I've been 40 years in war in all the war
well it doesn't select when Whenever
there is a bullet there is also
opportunist opportunistic people who can
interfere in the war in a way or another
for economical reasons for 3D resource
Readiness reasons
I mean when when the the guns Roar
things are not always under 100 control
because you can control the forces that
are immediate under your control under
your orders but there are others but in
such a situation and especially when you
are fighting in a build up areas and in
a town it is different rather than
fighting in an areas where we used to
fight in the in the bushes and all these
things where you can control the
situation here
this country now is the land of nobody
is a land of Never Never is the land of
everybody
very interesting to get your thoughts on
this Malaga thank you very much indeed
for being with us on Al Jazeera